getting started with Google cloud
platform cloud sequel cloud sequel is a
fully managed database service that
makes it easy to set up
maintain manage and administer your
relational database in the cloud cloud
sequel offers high performance
scalability and convenience providing a
database infrastructure for applications
running anywhere to get started with
cloud sequel first go to the cloud
sequel instances page in the Google
cloud platform console and select your
project next click create instance click
my SQL and choose second generation
enter my instance for the instance ID
and a password for the root user you can
use default values for the other fields
and click create you'll return to the
instances list your new instance is
grayed out while it initializes and
starts up we can now connect to your
instance using the MySQL clients in the
cloud shell in the Google cloud platform
console click the cloud shell icon in
the upper right corner at the cloud
shell prompt connect to your cloud
sequel instance and enter your root
password you should now see the my
sequel prompt now that we're connected
we can perform operations on the
database create a sequel database on
your cloud sequel instance by typing
create database guestbook insert sample
data into the guestbook database and
retrieve the data by selecting select
star from entries congratulations you've
successfully created a cloud sequel
instance
[Music]